N
USUALLY ANYWAY.
SARA, GREAT REPORT, THANK YOU.
>> CORRECT.
>> Sean: HERE WITH MORE
REACTION FROM HOUSE G.O.P.
MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY.
KEVIN, SO I HAD NEWT GINGRICH ON
MY RADIO SHOW THIS WEEK, AND WE
HAVE HIM ON TV REGULARLY AND I
ASKED HIM THIS QUESTION, YOU
KNOW, WHAT SHOULD THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY DO?
IT IS EASY TO POINT OUT ALL OF
THE FAILURES OF JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE I CAN'T POINT TO A
SINGLE SUCCESS.
WE SEE THE BORDER, WE SEE
ENERGY, RECORD PRICES FOR A
GALLON OF GASOLINE.
WE SEE A 40 YEAR HIGH OF
INFLATION, WE SEE DISASTER IN
AFGHANISTAN, WAR IN EUROPE,
NOTHING IS GOING RIGHT AT ALL
BECAUSE OF THESE POLICIES, AND I
HAD A CALL TO MY RADIO SHOW THIS
WEEK ASKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
YOU AND WANTING TO KNOW WHETHER
I THOUGHT THAT YOU AND THE
REPUBLICANS MEAN WHAT THEY SAY
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY WILL DO IF
THEY GET A VICTORY IN NOVEMBER.
SO I WILL GIVE YOU THE CHANCE TO
ANSWER.
>> WELL, YOU ARE RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO MORE THAN JUST
CRITICIZE, AND THIS IS WHERE I
HAVE A REALLY STRONG DIFFERENT
OPINION THAN MITCH McCONNELL.
WE ARE GOING TO LAY OUT TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, JUST LIKE THE
CONTRACT WITH AMERICA, I'VE
WORKED WITH NEWT ABOUT THIS, AS
WELL, IT IS GOING TO BE A
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA, AND WHAT
WILL THEY ACTUALLY DO?
I HAVE PUT ALL THE MEMBERS IN
CONFERENCE, WE HAVE GONE TO
DIFFERENT TASK FORCES, LISTENING
TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, WORKING
ON SOLUTIONS TO OUR PROBLEMS.
FISCAL POLICY.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE WE
TAKE THIS RUNAWAY SPENDING THAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE THAT HAS
CAUSED THIS IRRESPONSIBLE
SPENDING THAT HAS CAUSED
INFLATION.
WE ARE GOING TO BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
NOT JUST THE WAY WE WERE BEFORE,
BUT WE ARE GOING TO BE DOMINANT.
WE CAN ACTUALLY HELP OUR FRIENDS
IN EUROPE BECAUSE OUR NATURAL
GAS IS 41% CLEANER THAN RUSSIAN
NATURAL GAS.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE OUR STREETS
AND SCHOOLS SAFE AGAIN.
NOT DEFUNDING THE POLICE BUT
FUNDING THE POLICE AND MAKING
SURE D.A.'S DO NOT PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH LAW THEY ENFORCE
BUT THEY ON UPHOLD ALL THE LAWS.
WE HAVE THE PARENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS WHERE THE PARENTS
HAVE A SAFE IN THEIR KIDS
EDUCATION.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
ITEMS, BUT THAT IS NOT ALL.
WE ARE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE.
THE FIRST THING WE WILL DO IS
STOP BAD LEGISLATION.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT WHERE
THE ORIGINS OF COVID CAME FROM.
FROM VARIANT AFTER VARIANT,
DON'T WE WANT TO KNOW WHY AND
WHERE IT STARTED SO IT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN?
WE ARE GOING TO INVESTIGATE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHY DID HE GO AFTER PARENTS AND
CALL THEM TERRORISTS?
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO GO
TO A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN, WHY DID
WE HAVE 13 NEW GOLD STAR
FAMILIES BECAUSE THE DECISIONS
FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION OF
WHERE THEY WENT WRONG?
THIS IS JUST A FEW ITEMS, GOING
AFTER THE IRS, RELEASING THE TAX
RETURNS OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
AND YES, WE WILL NEED TO KNOW
WHO IS THE BIG GUY?
AND THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO IN THE MAJORITY.
NOT JUST MAKE OUR ECONOMY SOUND
AGAIN, OUR ENERGY INDEPENDENT,
OR ARE GAS PRICES ARE LOWER,
OUR SCHOOLS AND STREETS SAFE
AGAIN.
BUT WE WILL MAKE OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN TO THE PARENTS AND MAKE
SURE THIS CRITICAL RACE THEORY
IS NOT BEING TAUGHT.
WE WILL HOLD THIS ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE WILL GET THAT COMMITMENT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LONG BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
THERE SHOULD BE A CONTRACT SO
YOU HAVE A CLEAR CHOICE OF WHICH
DIRECTION YOU WANT AMERICA TO
GO.
AND IT IS NOT JUST FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS AN AMERICAN COMMITMENT
AND IT IS ABOUT AMERICAN POLICY
AND AMERICA FIRST.
WE SHOULD NOT BE DEPENDENT UPON
CHINA, OR RUSSIA, IN ANY
INDUSTRY.
BE IN MEDICAL, BE IT CRITICAL OR
OTHERS, WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
AMERICA CAN DEPEND ON ITSELF.
>> Sean: IF YOU DO ALL THOSE
THINGS AND YOUR COALITION, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY DOES ALL OF
THOSE THINGS, I WOULD ARGUE IT
IS ALSO GOOD POLITICS.
YOU RECENTLY WENT TO BRUSSELS
AND MET WITH THE LEADERS OF
NATO.
I PLAYED A TAPE OF DONALD TRUMP
DRESSING DOWN THE HEAD OF NATO
ON HOW STUPID THEY WERE -- THIS
IS I THINK IN 2018 -- BECAUSE
HERE IT IS, WE PAY MORE DOLLARS
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY TO
PROTECT NATO ALLIES FROM RUSSIA,
AND THEN THESE NATO COUNTRIES
THAT DON'T EVEN PAY AN EQUAL
SHARE IN TERMS OF GDP, TURN
AROUND AND MAKE RUSSIA AND PUTIN
RICH AGAIN.
PUTIN IS GOING TO MAKE CLOSE TO
A BILLION DOLLARS A DAY THIS
YEAR ALONE BY SELLING OIL AND
GAS TO WESTERN EUROPE.
I MEAN, THAT IS A FORM OF
MADNESS.
THEY ARE FUNDING THE WAR IN
UKRAINE BY DOING SO.
THIS VEHICLE YOU ARE 100%
CORRECT.
WE ALSO WENT TO ROMANIA AND
POLAND.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, SEAN.
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AS AN INDIVIDUAL
THAT WAS RIGHT 100%.
THEY ARE NO LONGER JUST SPENDING
BELOW, THEY ARE NOW INCREASING
BEYOND 2%, 2.5%, AND YOU KNOW
WHAT ELSE THEY REALIZE?
THEIR STRENGTH IS NOT JUST THEIR
MILITARY, THEIR STRENGTH IS
WHETHER THEY ARE DEPENDENT OR
NOT DEPENDENT ON OTHER
COUNTRIES.
IN ROMANIA, THEY ARE NOW LOOKING
TO PURCHASE AMERICAN NUCLEAR
REACTORS, SMALL MODULAR
REACTORS, SO THEY CAN BECOME
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO BE WITH
RUSSIA OR OTHERS.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AMERICA IS ABOUT THEM AND THEY
KNOW AMERICAN ENERGY CAN HELP
SUPPLY THEM IN AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND WAY AND
ALSO IN A PLACE THEY DON'T FIND
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
>> Sean: IT IS GREAT FOR OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, IT IS GREAT
FOR JOB CREATION, HIGH PAYING
CAREER JOBS IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR.
IT IS GREAT FOR LESSENING THE
LOAD OF INFLATION.
EVERYTHING WILL COST LESS.
IT SOLVES SO MANY OF OUR
PROBLEMS, AND W